[Música]
economía en directo América con Jorge
Hurtado Jorge Buenos días para usted
Buen día Ángela saludo y a las puertas
del inicio de la g20 en Bali y los
países más ricos del mundo ya se reúnen
en un contexto macroeconómico complejo
cuéntenos bueno es que sin duda además
de la guerra en Ucrania uno de los
grandes temas será el fortalecimiento
del dólar frente a las otras Divisas
también la crisis de deuda que ya tienen
varios países del mundo y por supuesto
la inflación que enfrenta el planeta la
última previsión del fondo monetario
internacional dijo que el crecimiento
global va a disminuir hasta un 3,2% este
año Comparado con el crecimiento que
hubo del 6%, el año pasado y la cifra
podría bajar aún más el 2,7% en 2023
esta es una desaceleración económica que
no se veía desde la crisis del año 2001
la crisis de financiera del 2008 otro de
los temas centrales será la inflación
mundial que podría cerrar 2022 en torno
al 8,8% anual el doble de lo que se
registró en 2021 y este es un tema que
preocupa al menos a un tercio otros
países del g20 según una encuesta del
centro para la nueva economía y sociedad
del foro económico mundial para frenar
la inflación los bancos centrales del
mundo empezaron una subida agresiva de
los tipos de interés lo que derivó en un
repunte del dólar en máximos de 20 años
frente alguna de las principales monedas
más fuertes del mundo Pero esto hizo más
cara las importaciones de bienes y
servicios de Estados Unidos así como la
deuda emitida en dólares de los países
sobre todo de los países emergentes a
que en América Latina también se espera
una discusión al respecto en momentos en
que las naciones luchan contra la
inflación pero deben hacer frente a los
problemas de deuda los analistas prevén
que se discutan fórmulas Como por
ejemplo la iniciativa de suspensión del
servicio de la deuda un programa que ya
fue usado por el g20 Precisamente en el
año 2020 cuando la pandemia golpeó a la
mayoría de los países bueno y el g20
anunció la creación de un fondo global
pandémico para evitar crisis como la
bebida con el Kobe 19 cuéntenos Bueno
este fondo sería gestionado por el Banco
Mundial canal y ayudaría a los países
con ingresos bajos y medios para
prevenir futuras crisis según bloomberg
el fondo recaudó unos 1.400 millones de
dólares de parte de al menos 20 países y
fundaciones como la de Bill y de linda
Gates así como de rockefeller foundation
aunque se estima que el fondo en
realidad necesite más de 30.000 millones
de dólares y no estaría relacionado con
el sistema sanitario los países del g20
comenzaron a trabajar en este fondo
desde el año pasado y tendría avances
concretos tras el encuentro en Bali
Bueno vamos a seguir hablando entonces
de inversiones millonarias anunciadas En
el marco de esta Cumbre Y es que el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
anunció varias inversiones en Indonesia
que abarcan áreas como el clima y la
seguridad alimentaria entre ellas
destaca un acuerdo de 2.500 millones de
dólares entre Epson móvil y la compañía
energética Estatal bertamida sobre la
captura de carbono las empresas
evaluarán el desarrollo de un Centro
Regional de captura de carbono en
Indonesia la asociación permitirá la
descarbonización de sectores
industriales claves según el comunicado
con el objetivo de ayudar a Indonesia a
alcanzar su objetivo de cero emisiones
antes del año 2060 byden está de visita
en Indonesia para participar
precisamente el g20 y anunció las
inversiones En una reunión con el
presidente indonesio yo cuido en otros
temas china Jorge estaría buscando
rescatar al sector inmobiliario para
hacer que repunte su economía y es que
los reguladores financieros publicaron
el viernes un plan de 16 puntos para
impulsar el mercado inmobiliario las
medidas van desde la resolución de la
crisis de liquidez de los promotores
hasta la flexibilización de los
requisitos de pago inicial para los
compradores de vivienda según bloomberg
las autoridades están permitiendo los
promotores acceder a más fondos
procedentes de la preventa de vivienda
según el comunicado las medidas
coinciden también con un manual de 20
puntos de la Comisión Nacional de salud
destinados principalmente a reducir el
impacto económico y social por las
políticas contra el covid 19 un
indicador de bloomberg intelligence
sobre las acciones de las constructoras
subió un 14% lo que eleva la ganancia de
este mes al 55%. los cambios se dieron
previo a la reunión entre el presidente
chino Sí y Joe y finalmente en Bahamas
se abrió una investigación criminal por
las acciones de la plataforma de
intercambio de criptomonedas ftx hable
no sobre ese tema Bueno
el fundador de esta empresa ya fue
entrevistado inclusive por la policía la
policía y la comisión de valores de esa
nación Investiga el colapso de este
exchange de criptomonedas esta
investigación se suma a otra que ya
abrió la comisión de bolsa y valores de
Estados Unidos te cuento desde el
viernes unas 130 empresas vinculadas a
ftx fueron incluidas en la declaración
de quiebra se cree que esta empresa usó
los fondos de sus clientes para realizar
inversiones de arriesgadas los problemas
acudieron la confianza en el resto de
las criptomonedas con monedas como el
bitcoin que cayeron en torno a un 20% la
semana pasada el director ejecutivo de
vainas que es otro importante exchange
pidió una regulación nueva pero estable
y Clara sobre todo para el sector de las
criptomonedas tras la quiebra de esta
importante plataforma complicado vamos
por favor a los indicadores empezamos
con los mercados portátiles asiáticos
que tuvieron un comportamiento mixto
mientras que las acciones chinas ganaron
terreno gracias a las señales de ayuda
al sector inmobiliario del país y en
Europa las acciones subieron gracias a
los valores del sector de los medios de
comunicación que se vieron impulsados
por la empresa británica informa Aunque
prevaleció la cautela luego de que un
alto responsable de la política de la
reserva Federal de Estados Unidos
advirtiera de que no suavizará su lucha
contra la inflación En referencia a
estos aumentos de los tipos de interés
Pues el agradecimiento para ustedes
Jorge y más adelante vamos a ampliar
sobre este tema de las criptomonedas
perfecto vamos ahora a los deportes
[Música]